I don't think that that moment terror  momentary forgetfulness actually  reflects what I know about Mexico and  how much I care about it and I first  want to say greetings to president lópez  obrador secondly I what I meant by the  game of Jeopardy is that I think we  could all come up with things you know  how many members are there in the  Israeli Knesset 120 who is the president  and Hernandez comes to Mexico I am the  one person on this stage that came out  first to say I was for the US Mexican  Canadian trade agreement that is going  to be one of the number one duties of a  president my colleague specifically  asked you if you could name the  President of Mexico and your response  was not yes that's right and I said that  I made an error I think having a  president that maybe is humble and is  able to admit that here and there maybe  wouldn't be a bad thing  you